[Musique]
normalement il ya boris qui nous a
amenés en équilibre dos au vide
franchement tu es le meilleur à je sais
mais je m'attendais pas à ça tape un et
la section mellor tu me la portière tête
pour tenir la porte du vécu monsieur
véhicules chantreau que mon corps boris
je déménage
[Musique]
j'avais complètement zappé que tu des
ménagères tu peux m'aider lève le menton
a pris 11 4 très bientôt je m'occupe de
toi ta quête pas c'est quoi cette tête
vas-y est
blessé mais ça y est enfin celle d'un
des cartons je voit enfin le bout du
tunnel on y arrivait à cowes ouais tu
fais voir le meuble à pharmacie mais
c'est bon j'ai bientôt fini mais comment
t'as fait ça ça tient avec deux
chevilles à 15h été demandé de vider le
meuble la pharmacie pas de le démonter
c'est pas moi ça bah il est bon plus tu
es sûr de paul comme au hockey il est
beau mais c'est par moi tu veux quoi ton
sur les autres je pense que tu as
cauchemar en mai le parti d'ahmed
arranger les cartes on arrête de
démonter tout et n'importe quoi se taper
[Musique]
allô c'est brice attendant toi tu peux
descendre
tu repart les mains vides tiens je vais
descendre tu as intérêt à rien des
montées pour la normalement bourhis il
va nous trouver une grosse voiture pour
mes bourhis non c'est le moderne
utilitaires ou grosses voitures c'est
quoi ça hellmuth ou tu montes pas non
gens vont pas non non
[Musique]
c'était cool au 7 bis 30 buts pour moi
la pause la voilà dans la vie cet homme
avait ce talent à bissau
voilà c'est ici
qu'est ce qui m'a ramené encore su je
sais ce que tu vas me dire c'est pas
grand dakar tel passé pas pour les gros
trucs comment s'est passée paquet on va
prendre les cartons un à un et après on
va prendre le matelas sangle en eau sur
le toit on va faire une sangle mes
questions raconte boris rend la fête ont
remboursé s'il te plaît mes frères tu es
sérieux quoi rend là et fait on
remboursé corps tu as cannes on a dit qu
ils ont démonté les meubles ni des
cartons faut bien que je m'occupe citer
qu'un toit fait le conseillant à l'eau
alors comment tu as fait un rêve vous
avez pas un plan pour vous avez pas un
plan pour louer des utilitaires si bien
sûr vous pouvez en trouver dans
l'application de chèques et si vous avez
peur d'oublier quelque chose n'hésitez
pas à consulter votre check list ou à
m'appeler si besoin ah bah ça ça peut
m'aider inversée beaucoup de soucis je
suis là pour ça au revoir monsieur
ouellet merci
alors mon gars abri cela s'est fait
plaisir là là c'est bien
tu es vraiment c'est parti on y va pour
east est parti sadi d'agréer les prix à
son mari changer la vie l'intention
n'est pas d'ascenseur quoi c'est au
cinquième étage sans ascenseur quoi
[Musique]